la parole est à monsieur jean lassalle
monsieur le président mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le premier ministre
comme chacun d'entre nous je suis
impressionné dimanche après dimanche par
les niveaux atteints par l'abstention et
le vote désespérer de notre concitoyen
dans notre univers complexe les raisons
en sont bien entendu multiples les
solutions difficiles à cerner et bien
plus encore à mettre ailleurs la réalité
est que nos intérêts sont
malheureusement plus un peuple souverain
pourtant passionné par la politique
notre alignement sur la pensée unique
depuis un bon quart de siècle n'y est
certainement pas étranger il n'y a plus
de débat de fort cette situation
alimente jour après jour les approches
simplistes et la tentation populiste
à l'approché des grandes échéances vous
vous apprêtez certainement à proposer
quelques palliatifs telle une petite
dose de proportionnelle ou encore le
vote obligatoire qui constitue à mes
yeux le niveau zéro de la démocratie je
suggère de réfléchir sur des dispositifs
qui rendrait de manière crédible
l'accès au suffrage universel et nous
placerait sur un plan d'égalité au
lendemain de la perte du mandat
l'échec électoral n'a pas forcément le
même écho ni les mêmes conséquences pour
le petit fonctionnaire
l'agriculteur l'ouvrier espèce en voie
de disparition dans cet hémicycle ou
encore un patron de pme ou un directeur
d'association voire un étudiant que pour
ceux d'entre nous qui peuvent
immédiatement réintégrés leur corps
d'origine
si cet objectif difficile à atteindre
dans un premier temps il aurait au moins
le mérite de casser l'image d'une autre
organe consanguinité entre principaux
décideurs politiques et hauts
fonctionnaires dont entre souvent un
sentiment qu d'oligarchie monsieur le
premier ministre
cette question vous semble-t-elle
susceptibles d'être pauvre on dit et si
oui car et de quelle manière
la parole est à monsieur jean marie le
guen secrétaire d'état chargé des
relations avec le parlement
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
député
jean lassalle vous vous interrogez comme
ici beaucoup de parlementaires sur la
manière dont nous pourrions améliorer le
fonctionnement de nos institutions de
notre vie politique et répondre aux
interrogations certains parlent de crise
démocratique l'attend dans notre pays
et sur ces sujets évidemment les
réflexions sont nombreuses
vous avez abordé la question de la
représentation et nous savons nous avons
vu la manière dont vous êtes impliqué
personnellement dans ce lien entre les
français et vous même votre travail de
parlementaire d'une façon à la fois
original mais évidemment très
intéressante vous poser maintenant à
travers cette question de la
représentation la manière dont se
constitue la représentation nationale
les différentes carrières les différents
statuts des parlementaires et vous
interroger sur le fait qu'à une certaine
époque peut être plus qu'aujourd'hui il
y a eu une représentation une sur
représentation de la haute fonction
publique
il vous plaît s'il vous plaît la vie
politique sur cette question
de nombreux parlementaires sur tous les
bancs ont déjà réfléchi et faire un
certain nombre de propositions mais bien
évidemment puisque ici il ya de très
nombreux parlementaires qui semble
sensible à votre démarche
j'imagine qu'ils seront nombreux à faire
très rapidement une proposition de loi
allant dans le sens de ce que vous
proposez et soumettront en débat à cette
assemblée
la l'évolution qu'il semble vouloir
voilà monsieur s'agissant du statut des
députés vous comprendrez bien la
prudence du gouvernement et je vous
suggère donc de voir les nombreux
parlementaires qui sait si merci la
cérémonie